[Musique]
allez on va tous à la manif pour une
russie plus démocratique surveillé par
l'hélicoptère personnel du président de
la lumière poutine maintenant on va
parler de la communauté géorgienne car
les géorgiens c'est un peu les
masterchef de moscou ils tiennent la
plupart des restos de la ville et
distille ou plus zine succulentes aux
pouvoirs magiques celle de vous rendre
sans terre pourtant la sauce a mal
tourné en 2008 avec l'invasion par la
russie d'ossétie du sud un territoire
également revendiqué par la géorgie ça
va mieux après une petite période de
guerre froide deux ans tout de même et
même si les deux pays n'ont pas rétabli
leurs relations diplomatiques
action séparations réconciliations
c'est un sujet le michael bordeaux
[Musique]
parmi les anciennes républiques
soviétiques
la géorgie est celle qui a le plus
fortement influencé l'histoire de la
russie et pour cause le petit père du
peuple staline était géorgien
aujourd'hui six à sept cent mille de ses
compatriotes juifs en russie
tamar est arrivé à moscou il ya quatre
ans cette journaliste géorgienne et
correspondante pour la télévision de son
pays
maintenant on va commencer tu es prêt tu
enregistres il ya du sang
tamara couvre un flashmob anti-poutine
une chaîne humaine formée par des
dizaines de milliers de manifestants sur
plusieurs kilomètres de long pour
provoquer ces dissidents des activistes
pro poutine ont organisé une
contre-manifestation
avec la dîmière poutine ma vie s'est
améliorée
poutine lui plaît et vous je ne sais pas
combien il est payé pour dire ça
il y a beaucoup de thèmes qui
intéressent mes compatriotes géorgien
mais spécialement la situation politique
ici en russie
et puis tout ce qui concerne nos
territoires occupés tout ce qui concerne
l'acadie et l'ossétie du sud
la géorgie
un pays deux cent cinquante fois plus
petit que la russie comme toutes les
anciennes républiques soviétiques
elle devient indépendante en 1991 après
la chute de l'urss
l'année suivante deux régions l'abkhazie
et l'ossétie du sud font sécession mais
c'est en août 2008 que la géorgie et son
président saakachvili
tente de reprendre par la force le
contrôle de ces territoires pro-russes
la réaction de moscou est immédiate une
guerre éclair de quelques jours
suffisent à l'ogre russe pour remettre
la main sur les deux régions
[Musique]
retour à moscou depuis la fin du conflit
la situation des géorgiens en russie
c'est compliqué pour tamarins exercer
son métier de journaliste relève parfois
du chemin de croix
[Musique]
c'est la folie regarde regarde la bat
serra va voir ce qui se passe ça
il ya parfois des moments où les gens
sont agressifs ils nous disent vous et
votre président saakashvili vous êtes
des ennemis laissez nous nous arrêter de
filmer mais je suis habitué ça fait
trois ans que je suis là
avec sa profession tamara un oeil avisé
sur les médias russes lors du conflit de
2008 elle a été la spectatrice
impuissante de la propagande
[Musique]
personnalisé que la russie était dans
son tort
qu'elle a occupé nos territoires qu'on a
été bombardée second autant d ici à la
télévision russe c'était des
informations vraiment biaisé
tout ce que l'on voyait sur les chaînes
russes nous ont le vivait vraiment mal
et pour cause en russie les médias
d'opposition sont quasi inexistants
l'héritage soviétique est lourd au
classement du droit de la presse 2011 de
reporters sans frontières le pays se
classe à la 142e position derrière le
zimbabwe l'ethiopie
[Musique]
si certains géorgiens ont immigré
récemment en russie d'autres n'ont pas
attendu la chute du mur pour poser leurs
valises dans la capitale soviétique
après un premier mariage raté avec un
géorgien anna perec nest épousa russe et
s'installe à moscou aujourd'hui ses deux
fils et gendre et ses petits enfants
habitent tous la capitale russe
est
merveilleux que nous soyons tous réunis
qu'un soyons une grande et belle famille
et il ya race à vous je considère que
j'ai accompli mon devoir d'être humains
et de femmes
ouanna qui a passé quarante années en
russie voir son pays d'adoption attaquer
son pays natal en 2008 a été un
déchirement
je vais brève j'ai fait un infarctus loi
si on ôte les îles kouriles et la russie
99% de la russie ne se rendra pas compte
parce que c'est à 15000 kilomètres de
moscou
a fait abroger
mais pour la géorgie prendre cette terre
c'est comme nous couper les bras ou la
tête
et caterina et la fille d'anna en 2008
elle vivait à tbilissi la capitale
géorgienne
le 16 août est une date marquée au fer
rouge dans son esprit
on a déclaré la capitulation c'était
horrible il y à une grande panique dans
la ville
votre gouvernement nous a informés qu'il
fallait faire des provisions de
nourriture et d'essence tout ce qu'on
pouvait
c'était vraiment terrible
en ce moment l'armée russe est toujours
présente aux frontières des deux régions
séparatistes
du coup difficile pour les géorgiens de
tourner cette triste page de leur
histoire
depuis le début des tensions dans les
années 90 des milliers de géorgiens ont
dû quitter leur région d'origine la
plupart en géorgie même et d'autres en
russie pour y retrouver de la famille
ici pas de problème d'adaptation la
communauté accueille tous les nouveaux
arrivants
regardez comme ils aiment notre
directrice
[Musique]
anna est la directrice de l'école 13 31
un numéro en guise de nom héritage de la
période soviétique
[Musique]
bonjour asseyez-vous
nous sommes géorgiens depuis toujours et
peu importe l'endroit où nous vivons
nous adorons notre culture mais bien sûr
on respecte la russie et on éduque nos
enfants en leur expliquant que notre
patrie c'est la géorgie
là-bas la géorgie c'est très joli j'aime
beaucoup la ville de batoumi en géorgie
par exemple les maisons elles sont
jolies
après les cours l'école a organisé une
petite fête surprise pour l'anniversaire
dana la directrice tous les élèves
parents d'élèves et professeurs y
participent
[Musique]
merci merci à vous et merci à tous les
participants
anne a créé cet établissement à la fin
de la période soviétique à l'époque
c'était la première école ethnique de
moscou une exception dans un régime
communiste qui prône l uniformisation
quand j'ai ouvert cette école en 88
beaucoup ne comprenait pas à quoi cela
allait servir pourquoi ouvrir une école
géorgienne alors qu'il ya plein d cole
russe dans lesquels tu peux apprendre le
géorgien et les autres langues
mais mon père me disait des filles ne
connaîtront pas la fierté d'être
géorgien d'être fiers de leurs ancêtres
il était très pointilleux à ce sujet
[Musique]
m
il y à 24 ans lors de l'inauguration
quatre élèves seulement si ray les bancs
de l'école aujourd'hui l'établissement
accueille plus de 800 enfants pour y
étudier dans la plus pure tradition
géorgienne
[Musique]
après la langue la religion constitue le
second pilier de l'identité géorgienne
tous les dimanches la communauté se
rassemblent à l'église orthodoxe
[Musique]
depuis quelques années l'église
géorgienne est en plein renouveau sous
l'ère soviétique le totalitarisme au nom
de la création de l'homme nouveau
persécute l'église orthodoxe de 1917 à
1940 soixante quinze mille lieux de
culte sont détruits six cents évêques et
40 mille prêtres assassinés
il faut dire que les persécutions
religieuses en géorgie était beaucoup
plus importante qu'en russie ils ont
pratiquement détruit toutes les églises
la répression pour ceux qui a assisté au
culte allait même parfois jusqu'à
l'anéantissement physique
il y avait soit la peine de mort soit la
déportation
et bien sûr on détruise et toutes les
églises qu'est ce qu'il pouvait faire de
plus
revenus de l'enfer l'église orthodoxe
géorgienne constitue aujourd'hui le lien
le plus solide avec la russie un lien
d'autant plus important que les
relations diplomatiques entre les deux
pays n'ont toujours pas été rétablis la
cicatrice semble profonde presque
insurmontable pour les égos
surdimensionnés des présidents poutine
et sa cage vide
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure de se quitter au
milieu de cette manifestation qui au nom
des sur prépare petit à petit une belle
russie pour le futur mais nous on va se
retrouver sur d'autres routes et sur
planète et quand je suis en beauce coup
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à
une femme cette fois ci c'est pas ma
mère c'est anna politovskaïa journaliste
russe assassinée à moscou parking on ne
saura jamais en tout cas par des hommes
qui n'aimaient pas la liberté
d'information et d'expression b comme
une première mais russe et comme le pont
c'est sûrement un ami penser à la mort
raccourci la vie alors pensant à la vie
yves lamy et à bientôt
[Musique]